[Musique]
c'est en fait un
le principe est similaire à ceux-ci
grandes chaînes de restauration rapide
tu conduis ma voiture et tu auras
avec nous le bon de commande que vous conduisez
une fois ici pour suivre le cours
je vais parcourir la boucle
[Musique]
Nous avons le temps dont vous disposez
apporte un peu de temps
mais c'est une très bonne ambiance
Donc autour de l'entrée c'est comme ça
de la neige artificielle et nous l'aimons vraiment
[Musique]
Mais en gros, ça aide
bien sûr, nous étions maintenant
générer des revenus là où vous pouviez auparavant
je ne l'aurais pas fait ou si nous devions travailler
Ce n'est pas tout à fait l'affaire de Noël
comme c'est normal l'année dernière
Les ventes étaient nettement plus élevées
[Musique]